death and the possibility of an
afterlife have fascinated artists
philosophers and scientists throughout
history fear hope dread these are all
things we might feel when we ponder what
happens to us after we die but what does
science actually know about the
afterlife if we knew that we went
somewhere after we died would we lead
better lives or would we shrug off our
earthly responsibilities knowing that
death wasn't the end this is what if and
here's what would happen if we discover
life after death death is not as
straightforward as you might think
the term clinical death wasn't even
coined until 1846 by dr. Eugen bushu he
suggested that if you listened through a
stethoscope and there was no heartbeat
for two minutes the patient was
clinically dead today determining
whether death has occurred is more
complicated the heart can continue to
beat for a full week after the brain
dies this was shown by UCLA's 1998 study
these 175 bodies were still functioning
one week after brain death called
beating heart cadavers were they able to
make the final jump into the afterlife
we can't tell for sure the closest we
can get to discovering concrete answers
is by looking at near-death experiences
according to a 2014 Gallup poll 8
million Americans claim they've had a
near-death experience
that's just in one country stories
across the globe described the same sort
of phenomena happening around the time
of death either being surrounded by a
bright light or seeing a being made of
bright light this experience is so
prevalent that Bruce Grayson developed
the Grayson NDE scale in 1983 the scale
determines if a person had a near-death
experience based on their answers to 16
questions such as did you see or feel
surrounded by a brilliant light and did
you seem to enter some other unearthly
world in a four-year study of awareness
during resuscitation the University of
Southampton found that 39 percent of
cardiac arrest survivors claimed to have
been aware of their surroundings before
their heart was restarted in most cases
the brain stops working 30 seconds after
the heart stops beating yet in this
study people claims they were conscious
for up to three minutes after their
heart stopped the survivors experience
is included time slowing down or
speeding up out-of-body experiences or a
peaceful feeling but the some even had
distinct memories of their surroundings
these experiences make sense when you
know that brain activity actually spikes
around the time of death a 2010 study
from the George Washington University
Medical Center studied the EEG or
electroencephalogram of seven critically
ill patients as they were taken off life
support the patients showed a spike of
neural activity near death that lasted
from thirty Seconds to three minutes are
these spikes in mental activity proof of
an afterlife well the short answer is no
neuroscientist Andrew Newberg speculates
that our parasympathetic nervous system
and sympathetic nervous system begin
operating at full speed in near-death
experiences these two systems rarely
work side by side and the combin
could create all those otherworldly
experiences that people report but this
too is just a theory so what if a
scientist makes the world changing
discovery of an afterlife how would that
affect the way we live well that could
depend on the type of afterlife let's
say there are different characteristics
of an afterlife and the way you lived on
earth determined where you go after
death if this was a hard fact that
everyone knew then we would probably
strive to be much better people people
would have different opinions about what
factors would be the most rewarded in
the afterlife and this would be a point
of conflict there might even be a whole
new field of science dedicated to
discovering the rules of the afterlife
but what if the opposite is discovered
what if there's just one place where
everyone goes no matter what they did
while alive researchers have found that
when reminded of death people tend to
shop more drink more eat more smoke more
in other words they live it up this
doesn't bode well for a reality where
the afterlife is just one happy
responsibility free destination it would
be easy for people to decide that what
happened on earth or to the earth
doesn't really matter there could even
be an increase in reckless behavior and
suicide death cults anyone
even if scientists prove the existence
of an afterlife the reality is they
wouldn't know how that afterlife
functioned the only people who would
know what it was like would be well dead
people's understanding about the
afterlife would still be formed by their
personal beliefs we'll probably never
know if there's an afterlife but luckily
for us we have longer to live than ever
before a century ago the average life
expectancy dipped as low as age 23 in
countries like South Korea and India
today the average global life expectancy
is 73 it would be wise for us to use our
longer lifespans to do good on the earth
that we have the afterlife may or may
not exist but the world we live in today
definitely does and who knows maybe
someday we won't think twice about the
afterlife because we'll have found a way
to become immortal but that's a story
for another what if
you